[Music]
you did a show recently with an Justin
Bieber and Selena Gomez were in the
audience is that right yeah I didn't
know that they were there I didn't know
he knew my stuff I didn't know Bieber
personally but he was in the larga which
is the theater here I'm a traitor it's
not huge pretty small yeah and I have a
bit in my act that sort of makes fun of
Justin Bieber and some of these young
pop stars basically it's a song it mocks
the way that those songs are written
which i think is what the songs
basically do is they they're love songs
to girls and they describe the girls as
vaguely as they possibly can so that
every girl can think that that songs
about them so it's like it's like I love
how your fingerprints are different than
everybody else's and like I love how
your eyes have that like bluish brownish
greenish color and you're like your
torso is an arm on either side of it or
like whatever and if you did hit with
duvet a predefined out if they were
matter well the thing is if that seems
sort of harmless but then it kind of
gets a little darker and sort of accused
as these these young pop artists of
being part of this cycle where girls
read magazines feel terrible about
themselves because it says you know you
should be skinnier you should be
prettier they feel terrible and then
these pop stars tell them that they're
perfect and that they're beautiful in
the songs they buy the song and then the
pop stars in the cover of the magazines
they buy a magazine against they're like
oh and it's sort of just like this
vicious cycle I basically like a sort of
imply that he's working for Satan or
whatever
um little shout-out to Justin who Satan
yeah that's great
but then when I found out that he came
to the show I just sort of felt bad
because it's like this poor 18 year old
kid like wanted to get out for the night
like with his girlfriend they they snuck
into the theater like through the back
when the house lights were down he like
grabbed her hand look into her eyes and
then I just told on him for 10 minutes
so if Bieber if you're watching I'm I
don't know why I assume he's in the
audience Bieber if you're watching I'm
sorry it wasn't personal that he was in
the crowd just to see a show where no
one mentioned him and yeah then you
ruined it now he's skulking out um Zach
stone is gonna be famous premieres
tomorrow night at 10:30 on MTV yeah if
you liked the clip watch it if you
didn't like the clip it doesn't get
better so a rare moment of honesty